the Porsche is with us in Atlanta did I
pronounce that correctly yes you did
how can I help today hi Dave I'm super
fan of your show I kind of just got onto
it
yeah I'm in the middle of my Total Money
Makeover I'm on baby set shoes so far I
paid about three to four thousand
dollars for full-time jobs Wow
I recently got engaged so I'm trying to
figure out how to get my fiance more on
board I kind of already told you what
we're doing I said we're not kind of
doing Christmas this year we may get one
gift
get your lucky she's kind of like okay
well just kind of let you handle
finances I know that that could be a big
thing if this one person is just
handling finances yeah that's that's not
a thing just you'll end up being his mom
I'm not his wife doing that you don't
want to do that you guys want to work
together you won't be telling him you
want to be a man you don't want to be
telling him how to do things we working
together on stuff you might be the one
that does the the numbers crunching or
whatever but he needs to be involved in
the decisions with you you ought to be
doing them together
husband and wife always so when are you
getting married
because I have so many I have the most
so I think that's probably why he's like
wow this is kind of your program not
mine
so I actually recently graduated law
school and passed the bar this has iced
over know where to go so how much have
you got with my student loan Sally about
two hundred and fifty thousand and
between my credit card debt and my card
that is a broader extra 25 yeah so have
you landed the new job well right now
full-time jobs I'm still working at Best
Buy so that's like my 40-yard job there
and then I work as like a contract
attorneys on document reviews 40 hours a
week as well so I do both of those right
now what are you making as a contract
attorney I'm making 26 an hour so with
the little bit
extra hours I'm so are you interviewing
for a good lawyer position well right
now I've only been getting interviewed
for a public defender
it can't be a public defender you have
$250,000 and dad yeah but I'm also
interviewing for private farms as well
yeah you need to be making seventy
eighty thousand dollars and get started
in a regular law firm on your way to 150
is you got to make some money kiddo you
got a mess
you can't take a government position
public defender pay what 50 grand and
the bigger city is pays a little bit
more its ups between 64 and 705 yeah
you're worried but see then but that's
it you're not going anywhere from there
that if you get that with a private firm
that's just on your way to 152 years
later so you need to get in for some
reflection you can make some money
because you got to clean this mess up
yeah yeah as much as you can where
you're working a regular law position of
some kind and yeah as quickly as you can
by the way we need to get that started
because you need the money okay cool
well I don't think you have to wait to
get out of debt to get married I do
think the two of you need to get on the
same page and that you're working
together I'll help you with that I'm
gonna I'm gonna pay for part of your
pre-marriage counseling part of your pre
marriage counseling is I want you to go
through Financial Peace University if I
give you that one year membership that
includes the nine Lessons the nine
Lessons can you get him to go with you
to the nine Lessons I can get that out
of him yes I thought you could I'm gonna
pay for it that's your wedding gift from
us okay all right thank you all right
you hold on and I'll have Kelly pick up
we'll get you signed up for that Merry
Christmas and that'll get you started on
the right foot but kiddo you got to go
make some money you don't have the you
don't have the luxury of doing taking an
underpaid lawyer job